[Applause]
[Music]
no Adele's not camera shy it's just that
her Vegas residency has been full of
surprises but yeah no it's been a
complete Whirlwind Adele's long-awaited
shows have not disappointed and the
latest well let's just say her crowd
work is on point and she had the best
reaction to an unexpected camera filter
my face
[Applause]
[Music]
and when the lucky fan became
overwhelmed Adele was there to comfort
memories
[Music]
but we think Mrs Affleck would
understand the power of Adele remember
when Jennifer was living her best life
at Adele's concert in 2016.
[Music]
thank you and speaking of Divas
supporting Divas
this comes after Dell spotted Shania
Twain Incognito sitting front and center
in the audience and Las Vegas is really
great there's always other artists to
connect with Adele shared her disbelief
on Instagram writing quote thank God you
had the Hat on I would have
self-combusted had I seen it was you
but of course she said the Anything Can
Happen Vibe on opening night of her
residency
[Music]
and to kick off weekends with Adele she
paid tribute to Sin City's Legacy of
magic acts like when she set fire to her
piano
[Music]
and by disappearing on stage
[Music]
cute sidebar Adele even did her best
Megan V stallion
[Music]
as fans of the songstress no Adele might
have wanted to pull out all the stops
after she was forced to postpone the
show in January we're going to
reschedule all of the dates and I'm
going to finish my show
and I'm gonna get it to where it's
supposed to be now fast forward to
November the show's drawing tons of fans
including Adele's close pal stormzy as
anyone knows I think that from
before I even knew her I'm I was a I
still have to stay a massive fan you
know what I mean and I think everyone
just knows that um
the woman that they see is as remarkable
as she is in real life
[Music]